hello and welcome to this video playing
new Mariano's here from UM from Spain
yes laughs I'll play that you on but
let's try them the Chiba nenko I've
played this some years ago with them
decent result a 4 is a good liner it's
tougher nowadays there are people people
have studied I have studied the opening
yeah are normally you take can i do this
i mean i just i don't like those
positions with takes and c5 they are
probably equal but only if black is
super precise and it still feels like
suffering and here i mean i just tried
to do something different put the night
to be four
b6 yeah so it's preparing me for him
only way to prevent that would be to
place you five here myself a funny idea
let's try it let's try it okay so what
does that doesn't look too bad I
actually thought that should be a
relatively for kig open position I have
a decent activity here on this side of
the board so Knight to g4 yeah okay I
have to let's play actively okay now I
can draw this night a 2 I don't okay
sorry the bishop eggs let's not blunder
the bishop now sometimes this is drawing
idea but the bishop was unprotected okay
night wants to come to deform probably
here right
I wonder if I actually no no I was
thinking I can maybe put something on
situations tactic with Bishop f2 yeah
Bishop c2 was may be possible one move
earlier but Candace is not relevant
anymore
probably some night to D for one of the
nights
no okay creature for maybe just wants to
take here maybe okay um not extremely
happy with this move but you don't quite
see what to do him it seems unlikely
that he will take I came job now I said
I do I would like it also all that much
I don't know this is a big threat of
taking them don't you let u 5m a v6 was
a little bit of a lazy move maybe I
should have played age 16 I have a 95 I
can actually drop back to g6 if I don't
see anything better I can do that
it isn't so bad I mean I'm attacking you
to the end nothing terrible happening
and I can maybe play age six night back
94 okay 93 bit about with strange to
allow that now is right in the middle
I've in this Bishop here do I have a
good discovery I can even even f4 is
some kind of square I don't really see
some really great discovery nighty one
maybe and then it will take see far
Angela you have to play quicker here
taking ages and probably in this
situation like every move was somewhat
okay i mean really useless to to think
that long check
so what's going on and where is he going
with the new a rookie a rookie one very
likely not sure how do I actually five
is an interesting move takes takes check
check check and it's actually an
interesting interesting plane now it
does it take I was thinking yet to take
okay
check
maybe just 93 covering this look 22 now
I cooked it true that will be difficult
for him to hold especially considering
the time white Horvitz on time okay yeah
complicated them and probably some some
mistakes them by both sides so said
let's see let's see how this is worked
out I just I just I didn't want to have
the situation that he gets an e4 easily
like this I don't know only have 93
actually here oh forgot about that yeah
yeah okay yeah yeah I should be
reasonably okay if i get rid of one pair
of pieces the dark squared bishop is
good to get rid of okay well i played c5
which which was interesting at least i
think take digs and then he took on d5
ma'am so I think I'd bishops it to at
some point which I saw too late here
Bishop c2 wasn't that possible this
interesting yeah this this and he cannot
take now because of Bishop f2 but he has
this funky move
interesting so I have to go here and
then 95 and he gets it back ok so I
overlooked that but it wasn't wasn't so
great um and Ti bishop age three I never
thought about that move but it looks
good right the unprotected State of this
Bishop here makes her this is an awkward
thing to face yeah so he could have
punished me quite badly yeah I don't
think that this this is leads nowhere he
could have we could have gone for this
of course here for them for this kind of
thing yeah I think white is definitely
better here in this ending the engine is
on half a pawn I don't know it's hard to
start to say how much better white is
but it is quite a sizable advantage ok
this wasn't i wasn't good year no 93 lat
FYI thought about it but I didn't quite
see if it is so good probably better
than this check this was interesting and
he went here I thought you would hear
then I would've if I was thinking about
giving the exchange here this was my
idea this Jack kayak and taking here I
thought I'd get this I bet he's got here
man so just just draw probably this
isn't doing all that much you can't in
here so but he didn't didn't go for that
into here I'm shy
certainly somewhat better pieces are
more active and a 4 is weak however he
does not have to lose that yeah probably
okay one was better now why is Bishop
before that strong trapping I trapping
the night he cannot really rescue the
night look for the look for that matter
okay yeah but I'm taking the a porn
cannot be bad and he's losing on time in
addition I forgot to switch on the della
success I still do sometimes yeah I
don't think it was so important in the
Sun in this in this game ok guys thanks
for watching